[Music]
Khloe Kardashian is keeping it chic but
comfortable during her pregnancy check
out the mom-to-be steppin out with her
growing baby bump on display after hours
of filming at the studio 33 year old
Khloe rocked a figure fitting bodycon
dress paired with a long fur coat and
strappy boots but after a long day on
her feet the reality star switched out
her stilettos for Yeezy sneakers and we
don't blame her I feel like my I don't
have swollen feet I don't have a lot of
these things because I am staying so
active right now so as long as I can I
want to keep that up Chloe is all about
keeping up her day to day life while
pregnant she and boyfriend Tristan
Thompson are still making time for date
nights ahead of welcoming their first
child the payor recently stepped out
during all-star weekend and the NBA star
couldn't stop cradling Khloe's baby bump
I think now that I'm showing more I feel
sexy but there's nothing like that
revenge bond naturally The Revenge body
host has been keeping a close eye on her
changing figure Chloe took to Twitter
with a question for all the moms and
expectant moms asking if in the morning
their bumps are smaller but throughout
the day their bumper gets bigger and
bigger
you